[Music]
hey guys we are so happy that you came
back for another episode of the wine
down today we are joined by Jean Amy who
plays ESA's brother amal to talk about
low key moving on yeah you and Molly
have just had sort of like in season one
you guys have argument in their fights
but this fight gets you guys physically
step to each other so do you think ISA
and Molly can sort of come back from
this I will say guys are a unique breed
like y'all fight and you become best
friends once women fight is so it was a
public violation there's an
embarrassment element to it it was a
qisas of it so I don't know how you can
come back from that without having a
fully candid conversation like for me
yeah I could never look at my friend a
thing it's like a mirror for broke and
then now you put it back together and
like you could still stick tracks in it
yeah yeah so wait how do you come back
from that how do you come back I think
great Kelly is brilliantly basic she's
sober she's basic and the fact that she
thought she was going to pass all the
south central London and I just loved
how knowledge is like lilting pokes
holes in her state the whole time and
she's literally trying to cover up every
time so one of the things I think we can
pose is I wanted to talk about
ESA's imposter syndrome at the beginning
of the episode and then finally giving
herself credit for pulling it off at the
black party that's real I mean we've all
had
we've all you know put ourselves out
there and there's no worse feeling than
feeling like why did I think that I
could actually pull this off yeah like
and but uh but she did it like no one
can take that she sure did you know that
energy is good right that energy of like
I don't want to be seen as as an
imposter ever see each of the characters
has had a lot of big ideas and not
always the best follow through and I
think this is like oh I've got investors
and people putting their money in on
this thing and this is like I think for
my professional career as well they're
saying like something that looks like oh
it's just gonna get seen about my
girlfriend this is like oh I did this
for the neighborhood and there is a like
her best friend didn't want to ask her
boyfriend because she didn't necessarily
fully believe that it wasn't one of
those schemes you know that it was gonna
be executed properly actually pan out
exactly so there's an element of like
proving herself and that pressure is the
[ __ ] wires do how have y'all dealt
with imposter syndrome when you know
you're capable I'm still working through
that right now like I literally googled
across the center in like and I'm like
I'm trying to work through it he's like
calling my cell phone my [ __ ] you know
journal and then the people around me
literally help yeah not necessarily that
I'm gonna be found out as what I'm
projecting something I'm not but that
Who I am isn't enough and that that is
that's exactly what it is I remember one
time I was on the show and what are the
best things I thought the show winner
ever did was say I don't know and it was
so freeing say that I just like oh
that's a very easy like nobody thinks of
you is less I think that's the fear is
that we won't be enough yeah I'm gonna
use that I don't know yeah well as
always thank you for wanting down with
us and be sure to come back next week as
we break down episode six
see you guys then
[Music]
you